alright one last law I'm going to show
you okay and up the question is what
happens if you have a number raised to a
power and then you raise that to a power
okay this is going to be a bit and you
are but we can approach it exactly the
same way we've done before so I'm gonna
put my example over here okay example
let's go with say how about how about
two to the power of seven okay
which I happen to know I think is 128
okay what if we paint it okay two to the
seventh everything in there cute okay
well the way I'm gonna purchase is we're
just gonna think about what it means
what does it mean to cube something it
means yeah fantastic this times this
times this three times let's write that
that's right then is to the 7 times 2 to
the 7 times 2 to the 7 right okay hold
on we'll get there I'll get a number in
second now
clearly it's gonna be very big number
but I won't know how big right except I
know something already and it's on the
board that will help me work this out
which index laws is which chalk cut can
y'all tell me which shortcut it's it's
the first one isn't it this is the one
with multiplication in it none of these
other ones are I've got a multiplication
in there so I'm multiplying numbers and
they all have the same base so using
index shortcut 1 I add the powers can
you see that 7 plus 7 plus 7 which of
course is 21 fantastic which is a very
big number naked your tails for this
seven to zero he had to be number V
number
okay so anyhow regardless of what it is
that's exactly what it's equal to right
you know you usually expect it's
actually can't do anything you can't so
what's the point though did you notice
right so you see there's two steps here
I really need to write them down I
couldn't go on straight here where did
the 21 come from where did it come from
yeah well yeah I came through seven plus
seven seven in other words three months
of seven right three Lots 7 2 ^ 7 times
3 that would have been a much quicker
way a shortcut to go from here to here
we're going to multiply the past so how
do I write this how do I turn this into
a law a shortcut that we can use each
time we see a question like this right
the base is still going to be a but what
happens to the powers fantastic
I'm gonna be even more shortcut e and
it's everybody M times n I'm just gonna
write M and you guys remember this from
algebra that when you see two curly
rules just jam together like that it
means multiplication exactly right